hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show outside the
studio after an awesome interview with
half of the filmmaking duo of the polish
brothers michael polish and their
composure um khubi owner on for Lovers
Only and we talked a little bit about
some of the the pros of using the 5d you
were able to walk around France and be
very inconspicuous and shoot this film
and you just appeared as a wedding
photographer or something but let's talk
about some of the drawbacks the camera
you know it was maybe this maybe this
Moray yeah that'll be a drawback that
some things do more a on this camera so
maybe this is going to be one if this
mores that'll tell you about the first
draw back to i can write you know it is
it is a digital format so it does have
its limitations in the way that digital
always has or the highs and lows of the
you know it's very hot it's the depth of
field is extremely deep and so you're
trying to everything these digital
cameras try to do is try and be like
film they're not film there it's it's
one of those things where you're always
trying to make it look like film but
they're now they're around so MIT
there's so many different books now that
people are getting used to this look of
a 5d or digital book so it's becoming
his own thing that people are bracing
it's not so much a film format anymore
of trying to be filmed I've said the
biggest drawback to this camera is just
always trying to make a little great
always trying to make it whether you're
the best thing about this camera is a
low light situation is you can go into
places a very very little
and I would say that would be the best
thing a filmmaker could have right now
is going into places of not needing as
much light hmm okay yeah you had
mentioned that it was great too because
in France there were so many places that
just had all natural massage it's
perfect yeah can you tell us some
interesting sort of stories of the road
um when it came to shooting I think
gooby was talking about his favorite
Charlotte yeah there's a shot in the
beginning of the film when Eve marks
character walks through Paris kind of
lost in his funk and just he's supposed
to take pictures and he walks down this
alley of trees and and in the middle of
its clearly overcast because there are
no shadows and then as he's walking all
of a sudden as if somebody turned on
like tens of thousands of watts of
lights all these light spots come
through the leaves of the trees as the
cloud disappears from the from the sky
and light him up and really really
underscore just how for Loren his
character is in that moment how lost in
this place and anyway if I had one of
those you can put it on the wall digital
frames that would be the loop that I
would have in my in my digital frame
it's a great job yeah it's what that's
one of those moments where you go you
don't even know you're getting it
because you're running around you're
running around Paris whether you're on a
motorcycle in a sports car you're
falling we even Paris when he walks
through there it's one you know he did
it one or two times we I don't see that
shot until we get back and I go whoa
actually you don't see the clouds you
don't see the Sun you just see these
trees light up and that's magic that you
know seven 7 eight movies and I don't
remember anything happening more like
that maybe I'm Northfork a couple times
but good nice yeah happy accident well I
would assume that it's great when you
have a camera that you bite the design
can just run the whole time and that you
obviously increase your your your
incidence of habit accident it just
because it
engine possibility and I know that guy
you know when you score the family sort
of like it to get to learn every once in
a while there was a scene where you just
know oh my god this was one where the
camera was just running and you know
there's like a little look or something
that that just sort of happens and that
then in the right context and editing
all of a sudden gets all this meaning
you would you would have never caught it
if you had just reversed the scene with
a you know a 10-minute film because that
is a big percentage of her lover's only
or it's about Mark and stana waiting or
sitting around or talking about the
scene and I'm photographing them stuff
in bed with her either getting ready or
we're talking about the same i'm
continuing with shooting them so she's
touching her hair she you know she's
fixing the pillow they're laughing
they're talking about what we ate last
night or where we go for lunch talking
about Paris so there's a lot of
in-between moments that that cameras
able to catch without exam okay we're
ready action and that's probably why the
intimacy of the four levers only work so
well mm-hmm very natural I want to
switch gears just a little bit and talk
about what are the secrets to a good
working relationship because this is not
your first project together so in a
marriage it's always don't go to bed
angry and they're like that so what what
what so we never sleep yeah uh well for
me um it's it's it is actually like a
marriage you pick the right partner
that's the biggest one and and there is
an affinity in the way that Mike and
Mark tells stories that that would an
affinity that I have with the way that
Mike and Mark tells stories so it's um I
honestly don't believe much in
quote-unquote working on relationships
they either work or they don't and but
obviously the one thing that I can have
with Mike and Mark is is absolute trust
when you write new writing music for
film is a lot like acting the longer I
do it the more I realize that and I and
actors talk a lot about how they have to
be able to trust the filmmaker and for
me it's really the same thing so for me
then it becomes a process of really
understanding the story and that goes
way beyond any verbal level is I'm
learning the what are we doing here
that's my entire job and and I just you
know I they have a way of conveying that
that all makes sense to me sometimes it
takes five tries but they're always fun
dries and and so that to me is really
the the biggest thing is it's a trust
relationship and I can trust those guys
I mean I would say having gone to the
same school helped a lot going to
Kaltura because to be in that school
there's an inherent nature that you have
an articulation that you have with
another hardest at you you look at this
is you looking Keller so you'll get its
basic training there's a training know
that you we have a commonality of how
artists speak to each other and there's
a Razors Edge that we really really
understand what's great about what I
really like about cookies at the
inventiveness but always trying to find
something new and it have even families
the best thing is it comes to something
else company on it never stops it never
ever stops working and that to me just
says we're going to get there we're
going to get to the place and
everybody's happy and for me actually I
really love the the process of failing
when you work with a good filmmaker
because my first attempt is always what
I would do and it's always pretty much
the best of what I would do with a
certain situation a certain story of
Ursa and and so every every every step
after that is something that I had no
idea was a possibility it still comes
from me obviously they don't say
make the whole ball play me flat but it
goes to the much more important level
which is you know the underlying the the
the the subtext the emotional content
the energy the pacing all these things
so step two three four five however many
it takes are things that I wouldn't have
done initially other words they would
have been impressed one and so once i'm
done with those five drafts they're all
mine all these new ideas all these new
ways of looking at the situation of
reading this character of reading them
you know the motion through the frame or
whatever they become mine and so it's
it's it's really it's a very parasitic
relationship as I can as a composer but
I really like it because i get to
amplify my storytelling in my medium but
and i guess it's the same for everybody
who works in any kind of collaborative
you know two actors working together
feed off of each other and then they
walk away twice the actor that they were
before this and so in a good situation I
really enjoy the process of rewriting as
long as you have enough time and as long
as you have collaborators where you go I
really like the way they go about this
you know I'm a fan of their films
otherwise it wouldn't work but since I
am a fan it's really a great situation